my name is Vanguard my body is an
aluminium sphere sixteen point five
centimeters in diameter and I weigh one
point four seven kilograms in 1958 I was
the first solar-powered satellite to be
launched into outer space
I had value I served a purpose and now I
drift aimlessly in perpetual orbit since
my retirement I have become a piece of
space junk the oldest human artifact
circling the earth I do not travel alone
millions of other pieces of junk orbit
with me rocket parts fuel tanks
batteries dead satellites before we
became junk we each had a use but now
we've become a threat
[Applause]
guys I don't tell you I think my faction
escaped once we get in depressurise that
outer portion it pop open the internal
hatch and it's time for peers to slide
outside that spears his feet in this
near the center of the screen
your Palace or spectrum of life div
leader object follower
[Music]
guys
if caught on the anywhere no dad I don't
hook ever to me ever feed on them we did
actually lose a spatula somewhere along
the way it accidentally got lost
Joe Cynthia Alfred Aruna levanto go
birthdays is a virtue Estella Mentos a
year air or vidonne man wat ROFL Anitha
kimono lol eventos mod n toda tanto
cientos de mille bellomont curve eaten
dentro de de la serda frost yet this
spatula like all space junk traveled at
17,500 miles per hour
eventually it burned up in Earth's
atmosphere
[Music]
you know after we learned of its loss we
mourned it because this factor was
really trying to get away and she got
away clean and went off to become a
satellite of her own and space debris
[Music]
normal meant a no imouto conocimiento a
la gente oh no se habla mucho porque
como el patio euro de lo que es nuestra
Mo's fira que la parte de los feminine
tase today from the International Space
Station this morning is the scene of
cautionary vigilance has flight director
Chris Edelen and his orbit one team of
flight controllers monitor the approach
of a small chunk of space debris in the
vicinity of the station that prompted
the precautionary sheltering of the six
crew members in their respective Soyuz
spacecraft space debris you know as an
operating astronaut it was just the
enemy everything between this and
teeny-weeny we can't see it we don't
know where it is so it's a sleet a sleet
of very fast-moving stuff with closing
speeds of maybe um you know one to two
miles per second
a piece of space debris is just 20
minutes and 45 seconds away flight
controllers standing by here in Mission
Control just 30 seconds to go
until the time of closest approach the
green light has been given for the crew
to back out of their sheltering
procedures with the piece of Cosmo
satellite debris having come and gone
with no threat to the International
Space Station for our colleagues
have a nice weekend this is Mission
Control Houston so we play the odds you
know it's a big sky theory that stuff
that we can't see will miss us and so
far you know we've been lucky it's
getting crowded up here some of us have
already collided with and destroyed
working satellites one more collision
click red cascade creating more debris
followed by more collisions our
destructive power might eliminate
current satellites altogether future
space exploration may also become
impossible
every orbital launch generates rocket
parts as debris as mine once did some
pieces remain orbiting forever some burn
up some land unpredictably on earth some
they say are guided safely into the
ocean
[Music]
we hire we whoa bye my little Anya
we're gonna let that go
[Music]
this is some of the debris currently
orbiting planet Earth we are a floating
graveyard apparently people believe that
harpoons magnets or nets could catch us
and limit the future damage we
threatened to cause but right now
there's no viable means to bring us back
to earth to bring us home
I think that the the business of dealing
with the unknown is what attracts a lot
of people to science a lot of people to
astronautics es s un par de Diez - emos
una visita de personas mayores and on de
uno de ellos me pregunto cierra normal
tirar cuando se mira del cielo dijo que
el sentimiento gallon bar GABA era de
muchas whoo sentimiento de mucho
profundidad dentro de
[Music]
I was home out of a trust by one hand
for a while
it was night and suddenly I saw the
thumb come off on the rise in the head
of me my feet hanging over the earth
I watched the dawn come up over the
planet and just come in a line straight
underneath me and then the Sun come up
and hit me in the face if you all see
the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
it's just like you're standing in space
you know make it or sitting in shorts or
something and it's totally in the
environment you become very very well
how huge the planet is below you and how
beautiful it is Vanga was America's
first satellite in space now there she
is
are still up there with a little whip
antennas waggling not in the wind but in
the vacuum space going around and around
and around quiet now
nothing happening but perfectly
preserved as far as we know so one day
somebody will go out there with a
butterfly net
when snagger puede ser sentimientos
entry motion Oh c'est de treat esse
tambien de incognita de severe no se
estamos express toes a que un trozo de
toe no Skagen SEMA oh oh puede que no
puede que esto que de or llegando dan
amante
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]